thanks Dan as mentioned earlier will be
using Android studio throughout this
course it's an IntelliJ IDE that is
optimized specifically for Android
development it's still in beta
development so your version may look
slightly different but that's okay the
core functionality should still be the
same if you haven't installed it yet
take a moment to do that now using the
detailed instructions provided in the
link below
you'll also need to install the support
library and that's also included in the
instructions
note that the SDK is included
automatically so you don't need to
install that separately if you're having
difficulties no ways at all we totally
understand because it can be tricky to
get everything set up properly you can
search online for people who have a
similar issue or there's a
troubleshooting link included below if
you still need help you can ask a
question in our discussion forum as well
once you install it open it and you can
check for updates before proceeding
check this box when you're done